if republicans and trump supporters
right now are
have no longer have confidence in the
elections
in the government in the system and
they're going to start doing their own
thing
and i they probably will so like one of
the things i said a month or two ago
when someone asked me like what do you
think it's going to look like if we do
see some kind of civil war i said
there's going to be a bunch of
right-wing dudes in the middle of
nowhere just basically saying
we no longer care about what the law is
like if they pass a law on gun control
saying
you're turning your guns they're going
to be like yeah who are you talking
about forget it
yeah and we saw we saw seeds of that
starting in the spring in january in the
winter
in january in richmond in virginia when
the governor and
the legislature there were looking to
pass very restrictive gun laws
many counties said that they wouldn't
have forced the laws and they were
joining together and resistance and
there was just a huge protest where a
bunch of armed dudes were walking around
i'm not sure if it was virginia or dc
i think it was dc couldn't have been dc
no that that's that was the point i'm
pretty sure
oh really yeah yeah fort fisher was
covering it i think it was dc i could be
wrong but it was basically like these
guys are
violating in large numbers gun control
laws
we'll see what happens oh i didn't hear
about that i'm gonna have to look that
up if there's a gang of armed dudes
walking through the streets of dc
all felony possession boom i can't
believe that they didn't get scooped it
may have been virginia
yeah that would it may have been in more
sense like yeah an apartment
reported it yeah was reporting it but it
was a while ago it was like a
week or two ago okay so i don't know
just see if you can google it it's going
to be opt out think it's already
happening
think about if you are a democrat in
montgomery county maryland and you don't
believe
that we should have restrictive
immigration and your county says
basically
hey if you show up here we'll give you
services we'll take care of you you get
a driver's license and if we arrest you
even for a violent crime we won't engage
with the federal
immigration authorities whatever so they
started this a long time
people have been ignoring the government
i think since
and even before it was incepted so that
was one thing i wanted to do i want to
step back a second and just be like look
remember 2016 all those all those
democrats were like
you should engage electoral college and
change the vote or whatever
and they're saying that you know it's
like so there's a video of a bunch of
celebrities saying
you will be a hero electoral college if
you vote your conscience and do not
elect donald trump
right amazing what are they saying today
well they're saying the exact opposite
and if you suggest that
you're a terrorist and a rebel and
whatever but my point in bringing that
up is
how much of these feelings that we're
having the sense of disintegration or i
won't respect him not my president and
all that or
like ignoring federal laws how much of
that is really new
that's that's what i i want to know
sanctuary cities have been a thing for a
long time
civil disobedience has been thing for a
long time ignoring federal guidelines
and laws regulations stay thinking for a
long time state republicans having
hearings in wyndham hotels like
d this is pretty good good good example
decriminalization and legalization of
cannabis on a state level even though
it's federally prohibited that's a great
example
of states ignoring the federal
government well disregarding the law and
saying screw you we're going to do what
we want that's different though why it's
just
i think it's the same thing when a state
says we want
we are a sovereign state you know and
we've decided there was a big wave of
states declaring sovereignty
you know i think it was like 12 years
ago or so that's
the states always have their own laws
and under you know and they can
there's a lot of laws that don't you
know work with federal laws it's
different when you have two
overarching cultures with 70 plus
million on each side
for the most part not every single
person who voted for biden or
against trump or for trump are you know
super politically active
there's probably a lot of people who are
just like democrat and you know
republican well let me just say
thematically then
it's the same in that disregarding the
authority of the federal government
deciding to do what you think is right
and not accepting it as legitimate
what's coming from washington d.c that's
on theme those roads have already been
traveled
will we see more of that probably i
don't
i don't i don't think so i think
sanctuary uh laws are like a legal
challenge
where the people in the state like they
agree and they vote for something
and then the feds challenge them and
there's a lawsuit and then the feds
ultimately back
back off right and then that that's
that's it you don't get cooperation
it's different when you have in the
state
in the same areas two different factions
of people
completely at odds with each other doing
different things as though there's a
different government or different system
for
uh um so would you take the monopoly
board and just flip it over and fling
everything everywhere and say we gotta
start over and get a whole new game or
are you gonna get up and walk away are
you gonna punch the guy in the face what
are you gonna do tim
man uh walk away
but it's it's that therein lies the
serious problem of what is what does it
mean to walk away in this analogy
i got a house out in the middle of
nowhere and i'm doing my own thing
and uh uh they the lockdowns are getting
bro we're we're well beyond the point of
these these dystopian novels maryland
announced they're launching compliance
units
that are going to patrol thanksgiving
looking for cars that
could indicate someone's having family
over compliance
units i mean that's as absurd as i saw a
joke
about like banning turkeys over 12
pounds or something like that yeah yeah
it was news them like no 10-pound
turkeys
no that was a joke that was a joke i'm
pretty sure it was a joke
oh i don't know somebody brought it up
but did you see the thing they said
about no loud music
no what does that have to do with covid
well not to be the party pooper on that
one but
loud music does induce people to speak
more loudly and enunciate more
you're not allowed to play music at
restaurants and i was like what what is
that about no
yeah the volume has to be low so that
you don't yell so you don't spit all
over everybody
i kind of which actually is one of the
ones that
only doesn't really make any sense to me
yeah yeah but they also said no alcohol
so that's fun yeah everyone will follow
that definitely and but you know i'm
seeing some pushback man
i'm seeing some pushback i've seen in my
local
jurisdictions parents getting together
and all and agreeing
that their kids should be playing little
league that their kids should be playing
baseball they should be doing crew they
should be playing tennis
that they should have group practices
and they should try to find events like
people are people are tired they
understand understanding the damage
that's being done to them
and their kids and their development and
their social development that's kind of
interesting to me because i looked up
the word feckless because i didn't
really know
and the root word of feckless is
irresponsibility and i think that
parents who are looking for ways to get
their kids out of lockdown
sadness are being responsible right
people are looking for ways to make
positive change or being responsible
people like this guy who didn't certify
are irresponsible
i have the tweet from ford fisher he
says today boogaloo boy mike dunn led
militia activists on an armed march in
laps around the capitol in richmond
virginia where it's illegal to carry
guns at protests
and it's illegal to carry 20 plus
20-plus round mags
police stood back and did not intervene
as the group defied both laws
wow this is uh that's a large group of
people
and they're twenty first carrying lots
of weapons yeah and violation of the law
and it's richmond virginia it's not dc
right he says he's got another follow-up
he says police monitored the area many
carrying long rifles themselves but did
not intervene
as the boogaloo boys marched by them as
well as signs reading firearms
prohibited beyond this point
other than pleasantries like good
morning police didn't really speak to
them in fact in the beginning of his
video you can see a sign it says notice
and there's a picture of a handgun in
with a red circle the line through it
so there have been protests before
there's been widespread civil
disobedience before
but has that been combined with
widespread factional violence
and 70 plus million people believe in
the election
you know or i should say to be fair
based on the polling we've seen it's
around
80 percent of trump's voters in various
polls 80 percent more than one poll said
this
do not believe the election was free and
fair so
we're looking at something like 65
million people
or so 66 million people who think that
the election was rigged how many
americans do you think have ever
seen a baseball game where they knew the
other side was cheating
and they just thought to themselves sort
of like well
you know if you ain't cheating you ain't
trying yep
that that's a that's a saying that's a
thing yep americans they fight hard
yeah so how much is there a chance
that if if they go through all of the
legal
process and everything is exhausted at
the end of the day
whatever the final arbitration is it's
like for biden
you don't think some of that 80 is just
gonna be like well
we'll get them next time yeah yeah i
think that's i think that's very very
likely
so that's that's it's conservatives i
mean it's it's conservative saying
well they're cheating and we know
they're cheating but you know whatever
so i'm trying to combine the
fecklessness you're describing
with this anticipatory conflict that
you're thinking about
that that we've gone off the precipice
and we're shattered i'm not saying
that whatever's happening is going to in
the immediate result
in you know marching armies or anything
like that or or
you know the republicans arming up and
saying you know
no confidence in the government or
whatever i'm saying
they literally are already having public
hearings outside of government
whatever that means i don't know but
they're doing it yeah
and and it wasn't like they they said
you know this is the official
off-site location like when they moved
the white house you know
to the other buildings i wish i could
remember the name of that octagon
mar-a-lago winter white house
i'm talking about in like 1800s man you
know but just a temporary location they
didn't announce anything like it was
just really just a dog and pony show
where people with credible credible
people
came and gave their testimony but not
even testimony they're just sort of
so that's that's the other thing i was
saying early on that perhaps what they
were doing is just trying to calm down
the hulk
they were like we need to make sure that
republicans
grumble and go home and do nothing so
we're going to give them their hearing
you're not giving them a hearing in an
actual building are you fine we'll do it
at the window i guess
then they'll feel like we actually
listen to them
the republicans are like right now in my
opinion in pennsylvania look at this
they're the ones who pat passed act 77
which
created the universal uh the no excuse
mail-in voting system
which according to the lawsuit that's
actually got you know
that's gotten the certification frozen
unconstitutional it was republicans who
passed that
now in pennsylvania the republicans are
holding these like
you know it reminds me of that joke
where they said both the left and the
right have said this about biden or
trump
make a fake white house put you know
candidate in it and then film a reality
show where they think they're president
so they're like let's set up a hearing
we'll do it at a hotel it won't be
official but we'll convince the
republicans we're actually looking out
for him
and you know i i you know i don't uh
know pennsylvania politics so so well
but uh were the people those republicans
were they
the old line establishment types the
neocon types were they or
not maga obviously i just wonder how
that went down
but you've mentioned a few times a
challenge that you think
has some legs right the unequal
treatment of the ballots and the voting
process and the cure periods and things
like that so this is the crazy thing
the judges and pa are basically saying
burn the whole thing down we don't care
and it's it's almost like the rulings
they're giving are them looking you in
the eyes
and saying no it's totally fair what
we're doing
and you're like what like these rulings
are just like i can't remember the
specific
case that i said the other day you have
to watch the other episode but it's it's
it's basically like we we've deemed that
uh this lawsuit is true and correct and
this is unconstitutional
but we're gonna allow it and then you
know we'll we'll we'll call the
legislature in the future to do
something about it
so it's like you you know that it was
bunk and something was bad
and you're gonna let it stand so what
happens when the judge said
what he said to giuliani what do you
expect me to do disenfranchise
you know seven million voters or
whatever and giuliani i guess he was
like
you know we don't know where these votes
came from in this case
the judges had they had two choices
if they agreed with giuliani and said
these 700 000 votes are hereby being
disqualified at the fault of the
pennsylvania government
for violating the election code oh now i
remember exactly what they said you're
going to love this
the judge said the election code states
there must be observers
witnessing the uh observers present
to observe the ballot counting process
but it doesn't state a distance
therefore as long as they're in the
building it's up to code
no sane rational person looked at the
code and said that's the point of the
law
we know why the law was passed as it was
because you want someone to observe the
actual ballot the judge said
it doesn't say what distance 100 feet
back
so when they sued saying we couldn't
witness what was going on
the judge said you were in the building
right good enough
that's the election code that is them
laughing in your face when you know what
the point of the law was and using a
technicality
sorry it's true and fear and then
laughing and high-fiving their friends
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time